[Music]
great welcome thanks everyone for coming
my name is DeWitt and my name is Ryan
and we're product managers on the Google
cloud team before we get started today
though I wanted to sort of pull the
audience mostly because it's this
afternoon and probably feeling a little
sleepy so how many of you are running
kubernetes in your organization today or
planning to run it well that's pretty
good we had a really good joke and I was
gonna say you with your hand down wait
six months you're gonna put it up I
don't think we get to use that joke so
and then how many of you are running
server lists today we're using a server
list platform good you all came to the
right place
all right well this is gonna be exciting
so today we are going to talk about two
things we know you're all excited about
that's true brunette ease and serverless
and we know that because you just put
your hands up and the talk is called
kubernetes so ever listen you and you
came but also we're going to introduce
two new things that you're just learning
about today one is the server list
add-on for google kubernetes engine and
the other is Kay native the open source
project that powers it and a lot of
people worked very very hard on this and
we're gonna try our best to do it
justice but if we trip up just applaud
really loud right then so let's get
started
so this is all possible thanks to
kubernetes so as you know kubernetes is
the open source orchestration layer for
managing and deploying containers I
announced only four years ago kubernetes
is now supported by every major cloud it
has taken off like wildfire every day
thousands of people contribute to the
success of kubernetes allowing real
businesses like yours to abstract away
the underlying infrastructure and in
fact it's that power of abstracting away
the underlying infrastructure that has
allowed us to think of infrastructure as
a smooth paved surface available
wherever you are in your
Center or in ours but that's only half
the story the other half of the story
for today is serverless
which is fundamentally changing the way
the developers approach building
applications some of you in the industry
may think of services only meaning
functions but there's so much more to
the promise of server lists than just
running snippets of code in the cloud
in fact we at Google see serverless not
just as compute but as the whole stack
that allows developers to focus on what
really matters that core nugget of
business value and not have to be
concerned with the complexities of the
infrastructure that runs that code in
fact Google has been working on
serverless for more than a decade ten
years ago almost exactly April I guess
we launched App Engine the very first
platform is the service and the very
first Google Cloud Ari one of the first
platforms the service and the very first
Google cloud product since that time
over the last 10 years we've continued
to innovate providing a number of
additional service solutions and today
we were very happy to announce the
general availability of cloud functions
that is that's super exciting but
there's so much more to service this
this is just a journey that's still
beginning and I'd like to unpack a
little bit what the promise of service
really is what do we see it as now at
Google we like to joke that serverless
is about no servers and obviously there
are still servers running a data center
somewhere but it's about making sure
that developers don't have to be
concerned with what those servers are
well that infrastructure that underlies
your application really is if you want
to you know bring a container deploy a
function or just an application you
should be able to do that regardless of
sort of what the underlying platform is
that it will run on it also means being
idiomatic
which is another google ism I think
which is really to say that it's native
to you as a developer it's meeting the
developers where they are so if you're a
go developer you should just be able to
be a go developer you shouldn't have to
learn a bunch of quirks in a system if
you want to be a node.js developer just
be a node.js developer don't worry about
how to integrate with the platform and
then the third promise is about being
event-driven today if you want to wire
up a bunch of different systems you
typically end up hard coding those
systems together putting all of that
logic into your code instead of being
able to declaratively bind things
through an eventing framework and we at
Google see one more promise here which
is that server loss relation should be
keeping you free of vendor lock-in by
adopting the promise of server lists you
should be able to take your code and run
it wherever you feel most appropriate if
that's in an on-premise data center a
third party data center or in the cloud
you shouldn't have to choose you should
be able to to keep using the framework
that you're using so kubernetes isn't
service if you think about it are kind
of two sides of the same pursuit two
things that go great together like
chocolate and peanut butter unless you
happen to be allergic to chocolate or
peanut butter and then it's absolutely
nothing like that but what kubernetes
does for the operator dealing hiding
away all of the sort of complexities of
the underlying infrastructure that
you're running on and allowing the
smooth paved surface service does for
developers allowing them to not be
concerned about the platform they're
running on and just focus on the core
you of the code that matters and in fact
we at Google believe in this so strongly
that this is the future of the way that
compute should be run that this morning
we were happy to announce the gke
surrealist add-on which brings all of
the wonderful operator friendliness of
kubernetes and all of the developer
friendliness of service together into
our Google cloud platform so the
benefits of using the service add-on
number one it's easy to start deploying
with less code today if you want to
deploy an application on kubernetes you
have to deal with a bunch of
configuration you have to write all of
that and check it in the service out on
makes this much much simpler and I'll
show you how in a little bit it also
makes it easy to run a server list style
workload being able to go from source
all the way to a deployed container with
a URL in minutes
it automatically deals with all the
network programming all of the ink
provisioning ingress and all the
different layers inside kubernetes that
you used to have to deal with before and
it helps auto-scaling and you might be
telling yourself hey kubernetes already
auto skills why is he talking about this
in context of the service add-on and you
write kubernetes does scale but the
service out on makes it scale better and
it makes it scale in a way that
kubernetes doesn't today we can actually
scale your workload all the way down to
zero which lets an operator in your
company pack more applications into the
same cluster resources and have
everything continue to run really well
so now that we've introduced the server
Louis out on let's actually show it to
you in action so we can switch over to
my laptop I'll be very happy good so the
very first thing that we need to do is
stand up a cluster with the serval is
that uninstalled and this is an alpha
that we're talking about today so you'll
see I'm using the alpha parameter in G
cloud but we're just gonna go create a
new cluster and enable the service that
on and you know if this works ah there
we go
so I got a couple warnings about
defaults that are changing but that's
fine meanwhile I'm gonna go switch over
and use the cluster that already exists
so that I don't have to you know sit
here and watch that little things bin
for a second or two I always like to get
started with a new platform by taking a
look at a hello world so I have a simple
hello world application that I've
written in go it really doesn't get any
simpler than this if you can come up
with simpler hello world let me know and
then I created docker file because the
way that this works today in alpha is
that it requires me to have a docker
file and deploy a container so this is
just a very idiomatic or native docker
file in fact I just searched for a
docker file for Galang and got this and
used it so how easy is it for me to
deploy this on my own box
it's idiomatic I should be able to test
it and run it here right so if you're
familiar with docker I can just do
darker build and I'll tag it with a
particular container repository so it's
gonna go do a little build it's gonna
produce a container for me this went a
lot faster in rehearsal there we go
and I'll just run that container real
quick so that you can see what this
application does you'll see it up puts a
little bit of log and if I go here oh
you guys should I cut what I did wrong
come on I need to expose the port in
docker to make sure that this actually
works alright so they're very simple
just hello world welcome to gzp next hey
it works man if I could get you guys
applauding at the fact that I took go up
and built it in docker I am I'm sad this
is good okay but now let's do the same
thing and actually run this in my
surrealist iron cluster so I'm gonna run
the G cloud server list command and I'm
gonna say I want to deploy a service and
I'm gonna specify the image that I built
and if you're paying attention you'll
notice I didn't push this but that's
just a save time I pushed this image
earlier so G cloud is gonna ask me what
do I want to name the service and it
provides a nice suggestion of hello
world I'll take it and now it's gonna go
out and do all of the lightweight
provisioning that's required to stand us
up inside the service add-on and
hopefully this doesn't take too long
because again in rehearsal really fast
done cool all right so now I have a URL
which is actually out there in life
and if I hit this you'll see hey there's
the same sample running out of my
kubernetes cluster and you'll notice I
didn't have to deal with anything in
Korea so I didn't use cue cuddle I
didn't create a manifest I don't look at
ya mole but let's actually go look at
the mo and see what happened so the
circle aside on installs of UCR DS that
make all of this possible the first one
I'm gonna look at is the service CRD so
I'm gonna do cube cuddle get service dot
serving if you have feedback on the name
so what this is gonna do when it finally
loads all right there's just my hello
world sample I'm going to dump the mo
real quick just to show you that there's
actually and will behind it and point
out a couple things there's a bunch of
status conditions on how the service has
changed but simply here's the spec that
I got created so it defined a
concurrency model for me that my
container supports multiple concurrency
and it just points at the container
image really really simple thing and the
you know it has the domain for the way
I'm being served from and the revision
so what's a revision well
the revision is actually another one of
the CRD is to be published and revision
is the immutable state of my application
so it's tying all of the configuration
details and the actual container image
together into an object inside
kubernetes that describes it and as i
continue to make changes it continues to
snap new revisions so it's easy to roll
back or to split traffic between
multiple revisions or deal with these
sort of multiple deployments that you
want to and then the last object that
I'm going to show you is the route and
what the route does is it is another CRD
that just connects between the outside
world and the revision that's running
inside my container in this case it's
using HTTP to route from that hello
world domain that was published to the
particular revision and it's always
pointing at the latest revision by
default but if I wanted to point at a
particular revision I could do that as
well all right let's do a little bit
more advanced example so this time
around I have written an actual
guestbook where you can post a message
and see it online using cloud datastore
as the backend and it just exposes too
little api's in a very go friendly style
of doing that and it serves some static
content using the HTTP file server
object but this time around I'm going to
pretend that I don't have docker
installed and I'm gonna say hey I have
this code how do I actually go about
building that code and having it run on
the service so again I create a darker
file a very simple one that installs
some dependencies and this time around I
am going to get in and build some Yama
so I meant to define a service like a
like g-cloud did for me automatically
and I'm gonna say that my source code
comes from this particular
git repository and I want to use the
master branch and then I'm going to use
the Conoco build template that's baked
into the service add on and have it
build that code for me and push it into
this container registry and then I want
it to deploy that container into my code
and so I'm gonna do Q pedal apply and if
I go and get my pods you'll see there's
this new pod that isn't the deployment
pod that's actually the build pod
spinning up and I'm gonna go out and
take a look at stack driver where of
course because this is integrated to the
Google cloud stack drivers automatically
plumbed through as well so I can see
what's going on
and I'm gonna search for build in my
logs hopefully there we go
alright so here's a bunch of build
output and you'll see it actually ended
up pushing the container now yeah
ignore the fact that everything shows up
as a warning like I said this is an
alpha there's a few quirks to work out
that might be one of them all right if I
go back here get my pods again the build
is done electricity I now have a
deployment and I can go to my guestbook
application and if everything works
right I should see some jespah countries
here what I wanted to see
oh wait all right I see why I jumped the
gun it wasn't actually running now it's
running
let's try again ah there we go
no it actually works and just to prove
it I'll put something and you'll see a
show cool now
that's me let's see what happens if I
actually throw some load at it so in
this window I'm gonna use watch cube
cuddle get pods and you'll see right now
I have a HelloWorld pod and I guess book
pod and I'm gonna run a little script
that's gonna throw 10 queries or 10
threads and 2050 queries at this thing
and you'll see that the service ion is
responding to the load by scaling out
the containers that I have here and it's
gonna make sure that all of those
requests are satisfied as fast as
possible by spinning up as much capacity
as it can inside my on my cluster so
that's really exciting the last part of
this demo that I was hoping yep there
goes so you'll see the hello world demo
is now actually spinning down that pod
is terminating because nobody in the
audience actually went to that URL and
so it's timed out it's hit the timeout
limit and now that pot is gonna go away
and so you can see it's actually saving
me resources inside my pod or inside my
cluster rather because of that um so
this is just a really brief introduction
to what the service add-on can do
there's so much more baked in here and
we're gonna we're gonna tell you a
little bit more today but tomorrow at
the same time slot actually is a very
deep technical deep dive into the
underlying technology on this that you
should come to you and you can learn all
about all of the intricate details in
here ok if we can switch back to the
slides
so just to recap the demo really quickly
like we went out and we turned on a
cluster inside kubernetes that deployed
the service out on so I didn't have to
load a bunch of manifests or anything to
get all of this stuff installed it was
just there by default inside my cluster
or there when I enabled we then deployed
a hello world up from a container using
the g-cloud command line to make it
really easy and then we built source
actually on the cluster safely contained
inside the cluster so nothing had to
leave my cluster by doing that and then
we showed how it scaled up and down and
then events is another big piece of this
and like I said I didn't have times in
this demo to show off events but come
tomorrow and we'll talk all about how
events work inside the space as well but
you know it's great for me from Google
to stand up here and tell you how
awesome my technology is but you
shouldn't just take my word for this so
I'd like to invite ROM from t-mobile up
he's the principal technology architect
to tell you a little bit more about how
tmobile has been using the technology
inside the service ah Don thank you Ron
[Applause]
first of all huge congrats on the on the
milestone so we're really from all of us
at t-mobile huge congrats to you guys so
choice of running the workloads in
different clouds is important for us so
when the Google team asked us to test
drive the server let's add on we can be
more excited so what I want to do in
this next couple of slides is talk about
a use case that we picked to run to test
drive the the server Lucero
so basically what you've seen here is is
we have this experience called store
locator
pretty much as you can guess this is
used by our customers to to see what
stores are nearby and so they can call
the store or even get directions so they
can go out to the store and buy buy
services so just to tell you a little
bit about the service that work you know
that's in production today it's
basically a java application that is
containerized and running in in our
mesas marathon container platform we you
know not only we had to build the
service we also had to write code to
actually collect metrics
send the the metrics to a time series
database scaling is largely manual
because we we get alerts from Ravana and
then we create dashboards to actually to
monitor and then when there's alerts
kicking in we go in and manually scale
it the other part is it's always running
even when the service is not used it's
always running which means it's taking
resources from the cluster so you know
which is you know those are some you
know if it's not used why take resources
right you could use it for other
workloads as I think Ryan and talked
about previously the last bit here is
there's a lot of investment that's gone
into CI CD to get you know proper
pipeline wired up to go from dev to all
the way into production so so we thought
this was a great use case because it's
not like always people are not always
using it you know usually when you have
to go to a store so it fits perfectly
for serverless scenarios so what did we
do
we basically ported the the existing
code which is a big java application
reported that just the logic required
the business logic into golang functions
and because we were building it on top
of the server let's add on we didn't
really have to worry about you know
writing the the creating the metrics you
know sending the the metrics to our time
series database and whatnot we didn't
have to worry about log collection we
didn't have to worry about scale scaling
order scaling and our devs just had to
focus on just bringing the business
logic over well we finished this project
in literally as a two-week sprint which
is kind of cool getting getting a little
bit so as you can see from this slide we
basically took the business logic code
and split it into two functions one is
the indexing piece indexer function
what that does is it takes the store
data and puts it into an elastic search
index because the the the the service
add-on is built on top of kubernetes we
were able to deploy a production grade
elastic search cluster into our same
infrastructure with with a helmet art so
that's pretty easy and then the other
function you see here is the query
function which takes the request from
the app and executes geo distance search
queries against the elastic search and
shows you the results so pretty pretty
straightforward now I want to talk a
little bit about where we're going with
it so today we have as I said earlier we
have store data in different sources we
want to actually kind of merge create a
basically a bigquery data set and have
all of the store data in central
location and then when when the store
data changes based on those events we
want the index to be automatically
updated so that our customers are always
seeing the most current data and then
t-mobile's pretty happy in to supportive
of open source so we want to open source
the store data set so that other other
people are other developers in the
industry can actually build something
that we didn't imagine right experience
so we run open source the data set we
also want to open source the function
code because the store locator is
something there pretty much every
retailer has the same kind of leader if
you look at Best Buy or or different
applications the the store locator is
something we see everywhere so we want
to open source that as well and then the
last bit here is you know we're always
looking for ways to improve the
experience for our customer make it easy
so we want to integrate with Google
assistance so that it gives a natural
language kind of interaction with the
experience I think that's about it
[Applause]
thanks.thanks wrong it's been a pleasure
working with you and the t-mobile team
and we really appreciate your passion
around the service technology that we're
building here and where we're gonna go
in the future and I can't wait to see
where you guys take this stuff to so
that's the gku service add-on like I
said it's available in an alpha program
right now if you would like to request
access to that please check out this URL
it'll be available for everybody later
this year but you know there's a lot of
time left in this talk huh t-mobile
talked a lot about open source - that
might be a good idea what do you think
maybe we should talk a little bit more
about that all right so thank you Ryan
thank you ROM so as we were building the
serverless add-on for gke and working
with customers like t-mobile we had the
opportunity to survey this space and we
realized that the marriage of serverless
and kubernetes is attracting a lot of
interest and rather than shy away from
that we saw it as a perfect opportunity
to bring everybody together to
collaborate that's what we're going to
talk about now I'm very pleased to
introduce today Kay native which
provides the building blocks for running
serverless workloads on kubernetes
and what I'm gonna show you should look
familiar because Brian just showed it to
you in the demo this is real technology
that we're deploying into our real
clusters and supporting and we believe
that's the right way to approach an open
source problem but you don't do it alone
doing this right
requires an ecosystem and we are very
proud to have worked with some of the
biggest and leading names in cloud like
pivotal an S AP and Red Hat and IBM to
codify the commonalities for running
serverless on kubernetes and we're gonna
hear from some of them today before I
get started though I want to I sort of
show you the landscape and show you
where in the overall stack we think the
K native fits it so we start first with
kubernetes the universal platform it's
ubiquitous it runs everywhere we take
that for granted and that's what allows
us to do this which is build a layer of
building blocks these primitive
components four essential operations for
running server list workloads on top of
kubernetes we're starting with build and
serving and inventing I but this is just
the beginning we expect it to grow from
here in fact I've heard this referred to
as the standard library for running
serverless on kubernetes and I think I'm
okay with that analogy in here we see
the type of products that we envision
being built on top of Kay native Google
is sharing a few of those with the world
today earlier today we learned about s
IP schema pivotal function service and
we'll talk about those now again I can't
emphasize enough so I added a whole
nother slide just to say it this is not
a science fair project this is not a 20%
open-source project that we're shipping
rather it's Google products that we are
taking the open source out of and giving
giving away and we're not doing it alone
earlier today s AP announced s AP kheema
which is based on k native serverless
components
and they say that K native will further
enable si P to accelerate enterprise
server less and event based applications
si P has been an incredible development
partner throughout and I'm really
excited about what's going on with kima
I they're around this week at the SA P
booth and I hope that everybody gets a
chance to stop by and see what we're
doing with kima an IBM cloud is
investing in K native IBM of course has
extensive background and experience
running serverless workloads at scale
with open whisk and then we are working
together and they are leading and bring
their leadership and expertise to help
bring server lists to a wider range of
applications developers and Industry
than ever before and Red Hat who's been
focused on open source and customer
choice since the beginning is investing
in K native to create a common building
block for serverless on top of
kubernetes across the hybrid cloud
absolutely wonderful working with Red
Hat very excited to see this in the open
shift function service and t-mobile
isn't just a customer t-mobile is also a
contributor to K native with their jazz
framework they are integrating K native
into the very fabric the T Mobile runs
on K native and kubernetes and jazz are
working beautifully together to
accelerate
t-mobile's move to cloud native
applications been fantastic working with
a partner and a customer who has so much
to add in the open source world as well
thank you Ron in fact this is the
beginning maybe the future of serverless
is going to be built on kubernetes and K
native some of you know sebastian
creator of KU bliss
he says the k native is standardizing
the primitives needed to simplify code
to production workflows it promises to
be a solid foundation to develop the
future of serverless computer it's been
amazing having some help out so thank
you
and you've heard me talk a lot now I'd
like to bring up my friend Ryan Morgan
vice president of Application Platform
at pivotal software who has done more
for any 4k native than anybody Thank You
Ryan thank you do it it's been fantastic
working with you and the team and I'm
excited to share with all with you our
experience around K native and where we
see it going but first why service think
judging by the number of hands I saw
earlier maybe I don't need to explain
this but at pivotal our mission is to
transform the way the world build
software part of that is being able to
deliver the right compute abstractions
on the cloud of your choice for your
workload the top thing on there the four
functions B view that is a really
important enterprise news case and it's
an area that we've been invested in
fairly heavily and that's a problem that
we want to solve for our customers today
then why Cain ativ about a year ago
pivotal partnered with VMware and Google
to bring pivotal container service to
market pebble container service was a
enterprise-grade kubernetes distribution
that's deployable to vSphere and has the
promise of constant compatibility with
gke we view kubernetes is a great
platform for building platforms and from
that we started project rift project
griffith had the top goals of being
kate's native with a focus on event
streaming and first-class support for
spring and for java but also for other
languages as well one thing we've seen
is when you reduce the scope of concern
for developers it allows them to be more
productive as the stewards of the Spring
Framework we've seen this with spring
boot and functions just takes that one
step further
but as we were developing riff we
quickly realized that there are some
missing pieces there's a lot about
container builds things about
incremental deploys auto scaling and
things that we weren't concerned with at
the beginning and at this point we were
introduced to do it and his team
working on K native and we realized that
riff and Canada were very complementary
the things that we were working on
really fit in well with with the plans
they had for K native so again working
with Google to contribute some of our
code into the K native project and you
know through that we then rebased the
riff developer experience for
event-driven functions onto creative so
really we're betting our future on
Kenneth and part of that is our first
release today so this morning at 9:30 we
released our first version of riff that
is fully built on top of K native I also
wanted to go into a few of the the
contributions that we've made today the
first is around the riff build and the
build templates that are provided within
Canada through our experience in cloud
foundry we have a lot of experience of
build box build packs offer the ability
to just push your code and from that
generate in the image sets in a runnable
build packs are very easy to write and
there's been quite a bit of success with
Bill talks in the past world we're very
excited to see what that might bring to
K native the second is around riff and
the and the topics and the eventing that
we were working on there and the
contribution of that into the channel
abstraction within canada's what that
does is it provides not only functions
but also applications with the ability
to publish and receive streams of events
for event based functions if you follow
pivotal you might hear us talk about the
value line the value line is the point
in your architecture where changes below
that line are not delivering value to
your end customers we feel that that
concept applies and open source as well
and in this case the building blocks
that Canada provide on top of kubernetes
allows us developers to worry less about
infrastructure and focus more on your
cut
so for pivotal this all means this
really comes down to a new product
called pivotal function service this
will be deployable and runnable on
typical container service and will
provide a common function abstraction
across any cloud or on-premise it will
have strong support for Java and for
spring but also will support other
languages as well and like all pivotal
products we'll have a strong focus on b2
and most importantly Israel built upon
components that are built within K
native so this is all very new this is
obviously day one but we're very excited
about the future of Canada and look
forward to working with you all in the
community thank you
Thank You Ryan thank you I can honestly
say that we would not be here without
the help and support and contributions
of pivotal it's been fantastic working
with Ryan and the team I'm really
excited about the future for riff I'm
excited about the future 4k native based
on the things we've learned in that
collaboration really been fantastic so
Thank You Ryan now I'm going to tell you
a very high level so this is very low
fidelity a little bit about what is in K
native today this is early on and we're
just getting started and I'm not going
to go into a lot of detail because
tomorrow there's a technical talk dev
209 where the tech leads will go in
unpack this a little bit more so right
now it focuses on the common components
that everybody needs below the value
line where you want to codify the
commonalities where you're not deriving
proprietary business logic but rather
something that's better off if we all
get it right ok so right now we're
starting with build and serving and
events so what does build provide as you
know containers are the lingua franca
the common language of kubernetes and
they're the common language of Kay
native as well but if you're a developer
like me you don't write containers you
write code so you need something that's
going to allow you to ork
straight the process of going from code
to container and what k native build
primitives do is allow you to describe
that in such a way that may be safely on
cluster with Conoco or in the cloud with
Google cloud build you can have your
kubernetes workflow pull that code into
a container but when you have a
container what do you do with that you
want to serve it so what K native
serving components do its allow you to
describe your workload in a way that
makes sense for the developer you saw
some of these in Ryan's demo the route
and the configuration the sort of 12
factor app style of development that
we've learned building server list
products at Google and that will allow
the system to do things for you like
scale it from zero to one or one to a
hundred thousand or maybe even better
100,000 back down to zero again right so
that's the type of things that having
these standard primitives allow you to
do and that's great makes a wonderful
day one experience but what about day to
day five day 100 when you're still
trying to run these workloads in real
production then you need something
that's smart about Bluegreen deployments
and traffic shifting and those are the
other components that are inside native
serving and you might want to serve
these over HTTP or HTTPS that's great
you can do that set up an ingress rule
set up a route but you may also want to
attach it to a larger event ecosystem
you may want to attach it to a git
commit or something being flowed off
your CI sed pipeline and what the K
native eventing primitives do is allow
you to describe in a developer friendly
way the binding from event producer to
event consumer and provide the
underlying infrastructure to make that
happen
so I showed you what's in the box let's
talk a little bit about why I made those
choices and how it got in the box so
there's some core principles that the
development team uses the first is it
should be idiomatic and by that I mean I
let's take for example kubernetes if
kubernetes has a way of doing things if
it
has a standard native way we'll we'll do
it that way we won't reinvent the wheel
with K native it should layer naturally
on top you saw the Kubb cuddle demo
where the exact same command line works
against K native as well and also we
shouldn't have you get a pH D and K
native to use it we should meet you
where you are if you're a node developer
who writes docker files we should be
able to take your existing idiomatic
node code and your existing idiomatic
docker files and run them and serve them
with all the advantages that you would
get second it should be extensible I
showed you these layers of loose
coupling build and serving and events I
and you should be able to in your
products they can choose among them you
may want build you may want all three
but it also should be pluggable at the
bottom we saw a demo where it was wired
into stack driver you should be able to
pull that out and put in an old stack do
whatever you need so we should make it
extensible at the top and pluggable at
the bottom and then lastly and I sort of
struggled to find the right word for
this but it should feel organic and by
that I really mean I we should start
from the bottoms up and codify the
commonalities the stuff that we all
agree on that need to be there we
shouldn't be inventing new things that
feel rough we should do the things that
you want in order to have a stable
platform for the developers in your org
so let's talk about those developers
many of us in this room are that persona
we write code all day and that's what we
should be doing for our businesses these
api's are designed for developers
they're designed to make a developer's
life easy they're designed to provide a
server less experience on top of
kubernetes but how do they get that
system well operators operators provide
these systems to developers in fact you
met an operator earlier today Ryan who's
operating the serverless add-on for gke
and your organization may have teams of
operators who are deploying these things
free for your businesses and maybe all
of us hopefully all of us
we'll also be contributors this is
something that we all want to work on
together to get it right and we strongly
believe in the power of open source to
do this so why is Google investing in it
why are we doing it it's clearly not
easy frankly we're doing it because you
asked us to you're moving your
businesses to kubernetes but you don't
want to leave serverless behind you want
to bring serverless with you so Google
is responding by helping out by building
serverless on top of kubernetes then you
ask why are we doing it in open source
well you also want workload portability
you want the freedom of choice to run
wherever you want in your data center or
in ours and we want to help provide that
through open source so to recap key
native is providing those building
blocks for running server lists on
kubernetes and today we're starting with
build and serving and events and it's
very early days and we expect it to grow
rather big from here and we're doing
this so you can run wherever you want to
run wherever you can run kubernetes we
think you should be able to run your
server less workloads and we're very
pleased be doing this not on our own but
with a very broad community of industry
partners and best of all and I've been
waiting to say this for a really long
time Kay native is open today you can go
to github I put this slide last so you
wouldn't all go at the beginning of the
talk but go to github comm /k native and
get involved we're really excited to
open it today so thank you
thanks to it oh thanks to it so that was
amazing I can't wait to get started with
Kenya oh wait if you want to get started
using this technology today please go
out and sign up for early access to the
surplus add-on I will be sending out
invites when I get back from them next
and we have everything ready to go and
of course you can go learn more about K
native today at that URL and go check
out the github repository and you can
install right to any kubernetes cluster
in fact somebody submitted a pull
request in the last four hours that
shows how to do yet another install flow
under kubernetes so super exciting
everybody's already getting involved and
of course this isn't the only talk about
this while we're here please check out
tomorrow especially at 4:35 the dev 209
talk with Vela and Mark who are hanging
out back there to learn all the
technical details well some more of the
technical details behind Kay native as
well as a number of other service talks
about where Google is going with
serverless
today
[Music]